ain't no party like a donner party
yeah one of jeffrey dahmer's worst
crimes is a recipe over at the new york
times a recent new york times piece that
delves into the growing trend of
cannibalism and contemporary fiction
you know i love contemporary fiction
it's why i read kilmeade's books
he's in bed already
the trend includes a slew of new movies
novels and tv shows featuring humans
feasting on each other and often
romanticized fashion
i bet michael moore tastes like foie
gras
[Laughter]
in other words not purely for survival
which is the excuse i've always been
using
audience seem to be craving it
apparently one of the co-creators of
yellowjackets a showtime series about
teen girls eating each other explaining
that we're often drawn to the things
that repulse us the most that's how i
got married
and that's why i'm friends with shalou
imagine eating him
there's more flavor and cream tofu
along with the fictionalized tellings of
human consumption the times also
highlight the many historical accounts
of real cannibalism the article caught
major flack online for normalizing
cannibalism of course many claim that
the press is the enemy of the people now
i know it's because we look delicious
tom
you know
what i figured you would know the answer
to this what situation is the is the
cutoff or the
where you can
contemplate cannibalism what if you're
stuck in an elevator for like four hours
no i don't think elevators no good
because there's always because there's
food right outside the elevator you got
to be off in the wild somewhere like the
classic if you're in a boat and then you
got you know you got to draw straws you
decide who you're going to eat uh i
think i would be delicious though why
is it because it's all white meat
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's right
that's right the choice is thighs the
best wings i don't know but we've always
liked cannibalism i mean we had soylent
green in our generation that's great and
then uh then we had what was that other
thing about eating people uh you know
the uh the hannibal lecter we all loved
that we love eating people we think it's
great
do we really
i mean it's what i'm saying is this show
is nothing new every generation has
their let's eat people show you know it
made me remem reminded me john cnn had a
host you remember resla reza oslin
yeah he said do you remember that when
he ate human brains on cnn in a
documentary it's like it just showed you
that cnn never watched their own stuff
it was it went out it went around with
some um some like kind of eccentric cult
and they actually ate human brains and i
think that was the last episode they did
i would hope so yes
it's the only time it's the only time at
cnn they actually had brains on the air
[Laughter]
i came up with that now
uh hate that america
does cannibalism deserve this stigma
john and have you ever have you ever
thought that you would be asked that
question uh no i didn't i think it's
very unfair to the cannibalists around
the world uh they're they're a large
sector of the democrat base and they
need to be
they need to be careful how they talk to
him but what what about the whole thing
about you're not supposed to eat meat
yes
right as a vegan you can't be a cannibal
no so that you know that cancels them
out out of the gate in new york times
there's a lot of vegans yeah did a vegan
write that article i don't know you know
what
in the mind of the new york times it's
probably more humane to eat a human
being than an animal right because like
we're oppressors
right
we're oppressed people right cat you're
an oppressor you're oppressing me right
now
i can't believe i can do that without
saying anything i'm so powerful
yeah i can't get all wound up about
about this article like i mean for my
28th birthday i did throw myself a
donner party themed birthday party
did you yeah i called it the donner
party party
i wish i had thought of it earlier
because i would have said i do have
photos we had like bonnets and like
severed limbs and we were at a bar it
was great uh but this article was just
talking about how like there's movies
and books about cannibalism and i
actually do think the stigma is a little
bit too high oh really yeah
cause like the daughter party didn't
want to eat each other no he didn't have
a choice and like if i'm dead you guys
can eat me i don't care you know it's
you know what you're always really
charitable and i respect i mean
here's the problem is she because she's
very skinny if you really believe that
you'd gain some weight so it would be a
bigger meal
hey this is one way to lower our carbon
footprint yes it really is and just feet
in general yes
the one woman said we're drawn to things
that repulse us the most if that was
really true then full frontal with
samantha bee wouldn't have been cancer
working a jab in there
i love the story of the donner party
because we used to always drive from san
mateo to lake tahoe and you'd have to go
through donner pass and my parents would
scare the crap out of us telling that
story did you know that they actually
cut up all the parts and put them in
wrapped them in paper so you didn't know
who you were eating and then you'd have
to pick it out like that isn't that
great
it sounds like you studied it i think
that's great i think that's really nice
thank you i think that's very thank you
for backing like i wouldn't want to know
who i was eating so if you don't know
who it is then yeah that was that was
very sweet yeah i don't think this
segment is gonna be clipped for fox news
you know they're not gonna go go to the
website and see the cannibalism section
no they're gonna lead with it on fox and
foreign this will show up on fox and
friends weekend how long before this is
a fox nation show
who's gonna yeah it
it's an eight-part series
eight get it
[Applause]
[Music]
still working hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else